what do you think of monogamous
relationships like philosophically can
you maybe steal that or make the case
form an alchemist relationships
um can you understand the pros and cons
of a monogamous relationships yeah I
mean depends on how you defend if you're
like hey uh we you can do whatever you
want but you and I are going to spend
the rest like we just you're 80 years
old and like oh we spent 60 years in a
marriage together we've never had sex
with anybody else I think that's like
awesome that's what you want that's
great
um I have like a little bit more
problems with people doing that while
also forcing their partner not to
misbehave if they want to
like if you're like oh I we only made it
this far in another relationship because
I forced my partner not to pursue an
intimacy that she wanted to then I feel
like a little like more like I don't
know if that's great how do you know if
it's a real want for an intimacy like
checking out a attractive person while
being inside a monogamous relationship
yeah how do you score that that's that
bad that the person cannot pursue those
feelings
uh I mean it depends if they want to
like I often find people attractive I
don't want to pursue
I'm also okay with people entering into
agreements like if you and I want to
agree like I'm only going to enter this
because I'm going to be so hurt if you
pursue somebody else so I'm not going to
pursue anybody else that seems fine to
me but I also extend that like if if
somebody's like I don't want you to have
any friends I'm going to feel really
insecure if you and like okay like if
you want to enter that agreement like I
feel the same way like I think you
should have the right to do it if this
is what you want but I also kind of I
feel like a little weird about
restricting your partner from doing
things you know oh but I guess if you're
honest about it just put it on the table
yeah I don't want you to have any
friends yeah I want you to sit in a box
yeah I think a lot yes if you're like
really on the but then if there's like
there's a power Dynamic that like you
can be quite influential in a
relationship and convincing your partner
and it sure sounds like you're honestly
agreeing to a thing but you're not
really agreeing that's the I mean part
of that is the beauty of relationships
right like
it's messy it can be messy it's hard to
know what you really want right I think
that's mainly my complaint with monogamy
like I'm down with like conscious
monogamy yeah but I think so many
relationships are like monogamous by
default like people sure it's not
actually right for them but they just
get in here because culture just doesn't
give them another option and they don't
even ask themselves the question is this
right for me like which like I'm a weird
ass person who thinks a lot of weird
[__] but I didn't even think about my
polymers an option before I had heard
that it existed yeah and I was only when
I first met my first polyamorous couple
and I was like oh that's what I am
that's clearly the thing that I am
yeah it's funny because to me monogamy
as is it's not a it doesn't make sense
for it to be a default like to me
monogamy goes against human nature
that's in some sense like romance is a
[__] you to the way the world works
really yeah like it's a like Romeo and
Juliet romance like
traditional description of what romance
looks like versus like sure there's like
a million variations of that but in in
my in my head like this partnership
that's for a long time together is a
kind of you know like uh I don't know
like True Romance you know that movie
it's a really [__] good movie okay
this is just like a
you're together
against the world
yeah that's the
I mean that's what close friendship
feels like it's like ride or die yeah
like that I guess it doesn't it it
doesn't it can be it could span across
multiple you can have multiple partners
in that way yeah absolutely but I just
don't see monogamy as like this
definitely not a default yeah I would
actually like honestly would probably
see polyamory as a more natural default
yeah I mean I guess it depends on what
you mean by default like most of human
history has been sort of a weird mix
like you get polygamy and monogamy or
the kind of the main sure but it's just
like human nature like yeah people are
attracted to other people and they want
to yeah especially in longer term
relationships I I tracked and my
relationship survey I checked the amount
of cheating over time in a relationship
like how long have you been in this
relationship and how have you cheated
what's what's the results of that men
cheat a lot a lot uh women too but
mentioned about 30 more than women do I
also asked men and women to predict if
they think their partner has cheated and
people's predictions were about the same
so people roughly predicted that they're
male or female like spouse uh hadn't she
about the same rate but mentioned much
more than women so who uh who was more
correct in their prediction though uh so
men were more correct in their
prediction predicting women and women
were that moon or more off women thought
men cheated much less than they actually
did
and but both of them were off but like
the male Gap was significantly more so
yeah I mean you're right when you say
monogamy is not default like I think
you're like really getting at something
like human beings are just especially in
long-term relationships difficult to
only want one person but to be fair I
think manami and commitment are very
different I think you'd be incredibly
I've known so many very long-term super
committed poly couples that live lives
that look very similar to the very
romantic monogamous couples like
children houses like 20 years yeah and
that that works great for them
yeah yeah
I mean there's so much to like open your
mind to in these
kinds of conversations these kinds of
ideas but I also like realize like some
of the cake is baked like I have some
assumptions that are hard to break
through like what for myself like it's
difficult for me to imagine a
polyamorous relationship for me that
would work yeah but I don't have enough
data I don't have a like I have very
little but like at this point
it's like um
I haven't eaten Pizza in like 20 years
because I know I just don't I
disappointing stuff I just eat low carb
because it makes me feel good but
there's so many foods I haven't explored
it's just like well I know what I love
so yeah probably you explore every once
in a while yeah and you kind of figure
that out but at the same time you're
humbled by like even talking to you or
looking at your data like with sexuality
is it is a is a fascinating topic
because it seems that we're very like we
were talking about very afraid of this
topic I like to be really honest with
ourselves about it the the whole like uh
academic research is afraid of it but
it's so core to who we are as human
beings